[Music]
in telltale signs new submitted by
Geodude here are 15 restaurant red flags
you should look out for when you go out
to eat oh I can tell you one one never
order fish on Sunday why don't they get
their ship they get their last trip in
on Thursdays every restaurant gets their
last shipment of fresh fish on Thursdays
time for the weekend
huh like everywhere around the world in
America usually like that's just
standard they get fresh produce every
other day and then meat and fish on
Mondays and Thursdays so Sunday is
always the last day of the fish also
never order any special that's a fish
because it's about to expire and they
need to get rid of it the specials is on
this list yeah so they're saying
specials are just food that couldn't get
sold so they're just like not that it
was actually special restaurants those
specials are something they're testing
to potentially put on the menu in the
next coming weeks so like how do you
know so much because they're dudes cuz
I'm married to restaurant is that what
your man does he is a restaurant yes
he's a Michelin star chef ruski what's
his Wow can he make one that is the
worst question to ever ask a shot any
real chef why because they don't like
they're not gonna say grilled cheese
their specialty is just to keep
perfecting their craft like they they
don't have a specialty a movie
what depending to know he loves French
food like classic classic French food Oh
beef wellington is Gordon Ramsay's
specialty it is they still have it at
restaurant Gordon Ramsay his Michelin
three-star restaurant so why can your
man not have a barbecue chicken I make
really good chicken and your Jesus juice
Oh brag about that I have Jesus juice I
heat up frozen chicken pretty much
something I drink in high school no it's
more of a remedy for when you feel in
sick oh your biscuits honey lemon and
ginger that's all it is gone that's
actually like oh that's great mm-hmm
how's about this what kind of food does
he make French and a 10asians app' knees
oh man really I
to eat this time yeah I'll come back on
when his restaurant opens and I'll
promote that so the first one on this
list is so first of all this was posted
on reddit
the question was chefs of Reddit what
are some red flags people should look
out for when they go out to eat
if the waiters jacket off in the back
okay okay good one who's that on it it's
hard to see that sometimes on first one
says a huge [ __ ] menu means probably
means you're eating out of the freezer
Chinese restaurant 100% I can't tell
yep some stuff you like see what he can
tell if it's frozen oh yeah that's true
that's true
Oh like rubber yeah or it's like very
seafood easier it's the frostbite in the
meat sometimes you can yeah the second
one says for my NYC people grade pending
doesn't mean that the restaurant is
awaiting judgment on their health expect
an inspection it means that they got a B
or C grade contested it and we're given
a grace period to fix their wrongs Oh
number three sick waits death the
restaurant owners encourage their
waitstaff to work while sick don't help
or don't help to find a replacement you
can count on getting sick - oof
number four specials are just leftovers
they're things that we'd rather selled
and throw out five ask where your
seafood comes from if they don't know
you don't want it most places don't know
well no they know if it's fresh because
they know there are suppliers or if it's
a seafood restaurant what do you mean
like if it's just a regular rush like
your the Denny's do like is the client
where's the clams from there like I
don't [ __ ] know if they're fresh they
always know where it's from okay then he
says first names well it's like is this
Alaskan king crab maybe they're more oh
yeah you do
number six gluten free basis we offer
them because of sales and somehow I'm
expected to make gluten-free gluten-free
food in a kitchen that's been pelted
with flour first
hours like a bakery also if you're a
white girl and you're like I'm not
really doing gluten so can I get this
gluten free you're getting gluten in
your food you're getting you're getting
whatever you don't ask for in your food
because that's how much they [ __ ]
hate you in the kitchen Wow who's that
because that your white girl yeah or
like if if you're annoying and you're
patron and you you know say oh I don't
eat pork because of my religion yeah
you're getting pork bro
what if I say I'll have a diet coke you
son of a [ __ ] regular coke they'll give
you regular you're getting Mountain Dew
I see yeah that's [ __ ] up cuz I worked
in a lot of restaurants and I never put
my like body parts and anything but my
friend did pretty well yep
have you heard of this red I don't want
to burn it out but it's called arroz
juniors of course orals juniors right he
was working there and he told me a sub
guy at the drive-thru was very impatient
and very very snappy and he was like
[ __ ] make it on a double kind of
thing and it was a very very hot day so
what he decided to do was get the
hamburger patty and pull down his pants
and wipe his very sweaty nuts from the
back of his [ __ ] taint all the way to
the tip of his dick with the [ __ ]
burger patty and then slap that [ __ ] on
and give that to him wait before he put
it on the grill cuz I just kills all the
bacteria that's fine after the grease
all over you TIR and then he's walkin
around the rest of the day with a slimy
but you don't want to fly me but don't
forget to subscribe so you could inspire
but that's how you prevent food tap ring
in your next [ __ ] restaurant meal
yeah that's what I was told people man
be [ __ ] polite and be chill to all the
waiters cuz you just don't know what
they could do to you behind there you
just like you don't know they could [ __ ]
in it spit in it what's waiting ya
server wrong - I also helps like if you
know somebody who was a server like
Nicki was a server so I know all that
[ __ ] and Mike you don't know what they
went through and [ __ ] so I just don't
even [ __ ] with it yeah even if they're
terrible I give them a 15% cuz I'm like
I'm like whatever I don't [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] what the dude you number seven
watch for no substitutions if the place
makes its own food they can sub
virtually anything for anything else
well they may try to play it up as our
food is perfect and we refuse to change
it on moral grounds it's always it's
almost always a sign of this was made
two months ago and all we do is reheat
it actually I'm gonna contest that one
that's not necessarily true because a
lot of the best restaurants do no
substitutions because it'll back service
up it'll take so much that efficacy
thing yeah it'll take so much longer for
people to other people to get their food
because then the chefs have to go out of
their way to like accommodate you and
your [ __ ] fad diet that you're on they
have a system I can see that too cuz
chefs they're artists yeah so it's
almost like me going hey
Kendrick Lamar on your other track can
you turn down the hi-hat no I wanted it
this way
that's why I visit for my track it's
weird to like tell me change it can I
get the song without the chorus I'm kind
of holding back on that part yeah
number eight salt shakers if the holes
are clogged and the top is dirty that
thing is being been real refilled 100
times without being washed oh yeah
number nine I've heard that if you
actually smell fish at a sushi
restaurant it's in your and your insides
best interest to hightail fish is not
supposed to smell like fish but I'm not
above gas station sushi really you'll
eat it yeah I will I bet 7-eleven
oh [ __ ] you're brave is there a
difference between that and grocery
store sushi no not at all which I'm also
not above and what I'll do with the
grocery store sushi is I'll go there
first and then eat it while I'm doing my
grocery shopping and then give them the
empty carton to pay for at the end my
wife is trash like you yeah she'll eat a
whole container of blueberries and then
she's like now you can ring that up -
it's like an empty container I'm like
that too but she yells at me when I
first took Robert like when we went
grocery shopping together for the first
time I did that with a bag of chips
because you can't do that like what do
you mean I'm gonna pay for it in the end
[ __ ] you mean whatever I want in this
car as long as I pay for it yeah that's
I never got the Kleins I just cuz what
I'll do is I'll just grab a bunch of
cherries and walk around and eat them
yeah but I don't pay for it oh I put it
behind in the aisles and the things in
it so anytime you see like cherry stems
and seeds that's me sometimes I get the
horseshoes and I drink it I just take
orange and I just squeeze it to fill it
back up and if you put it back inside
the refrigerator yeah that's awesome
number 10 brunch is just using up
leftovers from the rush of the weekend
generally the worst quality food and
usually worth skipping I don't know this
is all preventing food waste I'm all
down for it
this is also for places that only do
brunch like one one day a week Oh
expertise is brunch FIP
yeah or if they're like normally open
for brunch and they have an actual like
different menu for it which ones are
just like [ __ ] macaroni and cheese
scrambled eggs like okay you're just
reusing I'm so sad that I've accepted
brunch in my vocabulary
why is brunch like poop seem like [ __ ]
[ __ ] when I first moved to California
like sipping paint yeah yeah kind of
like that but but simply it's really
tight actually it's I always thought
brunch was for people who party all
night and then they want to [ __ ] they
woke up late and then they're gonna sip
on mimosas and eat brunch
that's just Denny's Oh Moses which one
so what's brunch then what is this
supposed to be is it for rich people
it's just the meal between breakfast and
lunch yeah for be very lazy
there should be a winner or a brainer
because I love breakfast for dinner I
can't do like french toast and [ __ ] for
breakfast ever
why crepe I can't just sweets in the
morning I need savory
yeah I can't do sweet - knowledge is you
savory all the times but like french
toast at night oh that's that's good
that's where it's at oh really I like
breakfast Olli
me too but I try not to do it for a
night cuz a coffee Gibbs you know I just
can't go to sleep
Oh coz you have to have it we've got a
half do you drink coffee with my
breakfast well yeah but that's breakfast
but when you're eating it it's just
desert on a plate but I need that bit of
coffee to wash down all that sweet and
and flavor Lee they always keep me
regular coffee it's true those [ __ ]
number 11 learn to identify roachie as a
smell and you can milk the [ __ ] out of
the door they wish bad grease smells
wait wait what is road she smell like I
need this explain I know it I know bad
grease but I like that I like bad grease
- it usually means they haven't washed
their flats also usually like ever
yeah just like dried grease have you
ever have you ever fried anything at
home yeah cuz it's it doesn't have a
smell in the beginning but later on like
that like if the Mexican mom cooks a lot
yeah a three-ton guys you've never heard
this it's just it's like imagine grease
that dried up and then it just stuck on
like the walls it's the foil that they
cover all over the stove yeah that's to
avoid cleaning but it adds more flavor
to whatever is being cooked on it's the
same reason you don't wash a cast-iron
yep I watch the video series where Keith
Kiefer Sutherland cook steaks and
[ __ ] lasagnas and [ __ ] and he was
covering his stove with with same [ __ ]
yeah that's hella trap but in the
comments were lighting him the [ __ ] up
cuz they're like your way shallower for
you keep a set the next trend now like
no more foil I just can't take plastic
straws and foil away from the trend is
this real celebrities dude you could
tell that he gets such a joy from
[ __ ] doing this but they hate
how much of lighting his ass up you
didn't being sad after watching that and
he doesn't want to do it anymore every
fun oh go check it out Kiefer Sutherland
cooking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]